so we're gonna stand this way together
and this is where our directions are
going to come in the hand and be very
important because for me to my right
I've got my floaty float to my left I
got my big tree in front of me I've got
the lake and behind me well I've got the
camera I've got you
you've got what you've got and you're
gonna keep track of that so you're going
to start you're going to make a circle
clockwise in front of you so your right
hand clockwise in front of you so to my
right the poise coming down my floaty
float to my left that's coming up my big
tree okay look at it on the lake it's
going clockwise right so for you you
know if you're looking at me yet your
screen that's going clockwise so if we
turn this way we can cross for words
because the poise coming down on this
side for me it's a floaty float for you
it's what you've got right and then I
can leave it with the lake and turn to
face it again it's going clockwise and
over here it's coming up so if I turn my
body this way with the tree I'm gonna do
backwards crossing and then I can leave
the poi on this imaginary I'm kind of
matching as a wall here with the lake
this is a clockwise circle so I look
over there I can cross forwards on that
side I look over here I can cross
backwards backwards cross and do a few
circles or what's crossing now I can
also leave the poi spinning with you on
the camera side it's like I imagine this
also kind of like an imaginary wall here
so also from this side if I look over
there at my floaty float I can cross
forwards and I look over here at my big
tree I can cross backwards so I can
always leave the point either side so I
can leave it on the lake turn do a few
crosses leave on the camera turn and
cross on this side and I can cross on
this side and pretty soon I realized
I can do some crosses turn my right do
some crosses turn my right do some
crosses turn back to my left do some
crosses back to my left so I've got the
four directions I can face and each
direction has a movement if I'm facing
my lake I'm spinning clockwise if I'm
facing my floaty float I'm crossing
forwards if I'm facing you
for me it's counterclockwise if I'm
looking at the tree it's crossing
backwards and with practice I start
being able to move and play relaxed
between those possibilities floors
crossing backwards crossing clockwise
forwards crossing clockwise backwards
crossing clockwise Lourdes cross
clockwise backwards counter clockwise
head mister what I want you get to and
this is what we'll take you know it's
gonna take you can play with this the
whole week and you can keep playing with
it next week getting more and more
relaxed with it and it's really the
foundation of a almost somewhat - what
we're gonna learn and the goal is not to
just okay I can kind of do it you know
get to the point or you can really dance
with it and what you need to keep
checking and this is where I want you to
be consistent but for me that's my tree
I'm always crossing backwards on the
tree or I'm always crossing forwards on
the floaty float now again those rules
in the long run you can break them
because in the long run maybe you want
to bend the cross point maybe you want
to take the cross with you right so
maybe you want to stall and switch you
know you can mix it all up later but
while you're starting it's really
helpful to be consistent so you can get
out with each hand I'll stick your left
hand same thing
this is forwards crossing this is
backwards crossing this is forwards
crossing this is backwards frosting
counterclockwise clockwise when that's
all supernatural and you're relaxed you
feel like you're dancing and music on
just play with that I think it's
stretching reaching forward reaching
down reaching up coming here turning
this way
that's when you're ready to progress and
if this is your this is you make a good
foundation you're getting you're going
to be great if you rush ahead before
this is smooth you'll have a lot more
frustration so I hope you all play with
me on this and really get this into your
body and then it's going to be it's
going to be really smooth as we progress
through all the other patterns movements
and explorations and dance